tengo esta función pdte que esto esta
expresión locochona y sé que la posición
de una partícula está dada por esta
función
esta función puede ser positiva o
negativa o 0 no sé pero bueno entonces
la expresión este menos a por a menos
deporte menos a parte de todo eso entre
la raíz cuadrada de cuadrada más b
cuadrada y me dicen que ese es mayor que
bay que es mayor que es mayor que 0 por
acá abajo tengo estos dos enunciados por
así llamarlos tengo el valor de pdc y el
número de veces que la función es igual
a cero así que lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es determinar cuál de estas
dos si alguna cuál de estas dos
cantidades es mayor o si son iguales o
si no hay suficiente información para
contestar esto así que los invito a
pasar el vídeo y si ya lo hicieron vamos
a proceder comencemos con pdc comencemos
con esto entonces cuánto vale pd cm
pues pdc vale si simplemente sustituyó t
igual hace obtengo se menos a
por menos a menos por ser menos de nuevo
por se ve y todo eso dividido entre la
raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada más de
cuadrada
ahora bien cuánto puede valer esto pues
la verdad si no sé cuánto valen
exactamente se ya no tengo muchas
esperanzas de poder determinar el valor
de esto pero quizás utilizando esta
información puede decir si es un número
positivo o negativo así que bien
usemos que ese es mayor que ve que es
mayor que a que es mayor que cero
entonces se menos a cómo sería pues se
es mayor que a entonces esto es un
número positivo a menos
cissé menos a es positivo a menos se
tiene que ser negativo de menos a de
nuevo otra vez es positivo y se menos b
es positivo recuerden que es mayor que
ve que es mayor que a que es mayor que
cero por lo tanto se nos ve y se menos
son números positivos y menos c es
negativo ahora esto en el denominador la
raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada más b
cuadrada siempre es un número positivo
de modo que cuanto es esto o qué signo
tiene esto un positivo por un negativo
por un positivo pregunta es positivo es
un negativo podría primero multiplicar
los tres positivos obtengo un número
positivo lo multiplicó por un negativo y
obtengo
negativo así que tengo un negativo
dividido entre un positivo
de modo que esto de aquí debe ser un
número negativo
negativo
es decir p - es negativo
o en todo caso puedo decir que es menor
que cero noten que todo está bien
definido precisamente porque ni se me
venía son cero y cuadrada más de
cuadradas no puede ser cero ok entonces
si esto es un número negativo si esto
resulta ser un número positivo que de
hecho tiene que ser un número positivo a
cero porque es el número de veces que p
dt es igual a cero entonces podría decir
que esta columna sería más grande pero
bueno vamos a calcular explícitamente
cuántas veces esto es cero pues veamos
tengo que el numerador de petete está
compuesto por estos cuatro factores de
menos a menos te de menos a de nuevo y
te menos b entonces cuando puedo anular
tdt
pues sí sólos y anuló el numerador y eso
pasa así solo si alguno de estos
factores es cero el primer factor es
cero cuando te es igual a si te es igual
a entonces a menos a es cero el segundo
factor es igual a cero también cuando te
es iguala el tercer factor también
cuando te des iguala y el cuarto cuando
te es igual a b
es igual a mí y esas son las únicas dos
posibilidades que tengo para anular este
es el numerador y por lo tanto toda esta
expresión de modo que el número de veces
que pdte es igual a cero es
2 hay dos números en el que dos valores
para t en el que [ __ ] es igual a cero de
modo que la respuesta correcta sería
esta el número de veces que p dt es
igual a cero es en cantidad mayor que el
valor de pdc